[Musique]
elle si souvent Beyoncé comme modèle de
femme complète mais elle ne l'est pas
moins humoriste comédienne dans suce
chorégraphe est désormais à la tête de
sa propre série sur Netflix l'emploi
s'étalant et sa pugnacité sur tous les
fronts en menant une vie à son à l'heure
sur les deux rives de la Méditerranée et
les deux côtés de l'Atlantique et s'il
était temps de se poser un peu pour
faire le point d'avoir le Madani est en
aparté
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que c'est que ça bah oui moi
je viens je viens déjà avec un cadeau
parce qu'on m'invite je viens pas les
mains vides c'est trop mignon ça et puis
je viens en famille voilà avec Tupac
Tupac Tupac Madani pardon je crois qu'il
a même son compte Instagram vrai ou pas
exactement il y a eu Drucker Dechavanne
et Nawel Madani avec son chien
bienvenue Bienvenue chez vous un peu
chez vous un peu chez nous
spectacle comme je suis une vraie meuf
je me regarde un petit peu pour voir si
je suis bien mais vous êtes très bien
bon alors qu'est-ce qu'on a dans cette
mallette dans cette petite valise en
osier j'ai l'impression ouais alors elle
elle s'appelle jusqu'ici tout va bien
comme la série exactement et du coup
dedans j'ai mis des petites trucs
je crois que c'est la première fois
attendez je vais me pincer parce que
sincèrement c'est vrai ah bah oui oui
les gens viennent chez vous les mains
vides on est à quoi on est à 280
émissions à peu près ouais ouais c'est
absolument la première fois ah bah dis
donc
je suis heureuse en plus je vous ai
ramené du thé oh c'est trop mignon du
thé une petite théière comme ça on sait
jamais
bon mais quelle délicatesse de la pâte à
tartiner je vous ai ramené des dates oh
voilà des dates d'Oran elles sont pas
d'Oran mais elles ont le goût d'Oran
[Rires]
derrière vous avez reconnu ça y est
Santa Cruz
ah non mais là une plage en particulier
la plage des andalouse peut-être
incroyable
on avait envie de vous faire voyager
c'est quoi ces quatre heures d'avion à
peine non 2h30
2h30 c'est génial mais ça c'est toute ma
vie ça c'est ah ouais vous avez commencé
vous savez que je suis hyper sensible
moi je suis motive
ce sont des bons vivants c'est ça ouais
un peu trop c'est mon papa mais mes deux
parents viennent ouais ils viennent ils
viennent d'Oran c'est c'est une ville
qui a bercé toute mon enfance j'ai passé
les meilleures vacances
[Musique]
et j'arrêtais pas de de promener
l'ouverture d'esprit des Algériens et je
me suis dit à la meilleure façon c'est
d'y aller et de le filmer et j'avais
peur parce qu'il fallait que je relève
le challenge
Canal+ m'a suivi sur cette folle
aventure et on ouvre la billetterie et
on fait quatre opéras d'Alger
et les gens sont venus de de Constantine
d'Annaba de moustaganem ils ont fait des
7 heures de route ils dormaient dans la
voiture pour venir voir le spectacle je
n'ai jamais eu un accueil pareil les
familles des familles étaient là de la
grand-mère à la petite fille on était
j'ai fait trois heures de show
j'ai ramené avec moi romane Frayssinet
Redouane bougaraba et ainsi de suite on
était tous sur scène et on a reçu
tellement de Love
j'étais heureuse de capturer ces images
et d'en faire un magnifique documentaire
Nawel c'est merci encore mille fois et
merci pour votre délicate attention avec
cette petite valise bien garnie c'est
vraiment hyper mignon de votre part très
délicat on va remonter le fil dans
quelques instants mais on va bien sûr
parler si vous voulez bien vous
installer dans le canapé ou ailleurs
comme vous voulez
on va parler de jusqu'ici tout va bien
comme le nom de la valise que vous avez
créé avec Simon jablonca et dans
laquelle vous jouez avec Kahina Karina
Paola locachelli Djibril zonga et Karima
Amarouche c'est disponible sur Netflix
comme on dit je lis binja vraiment
jusqu'à 2h15 du matin à cause de vous je
me suis couché extrêmement tard mais
j'ai été méprise emportée par cette
histoire cette journaliste incarnée par
vous-même qui sombre dans dans le chaos
parce qu'elle décide évidemment et
qu'elle est confrontée à ça d'aider son
frère qui qui est pris dans les
turpitudes de trafic ce frère qui doit
échapper à la police elle met sa famille
dans la ligne de mire d'un baron de la
drogue et l'embarque ses sœurs sa mère
toutes les générations confondues sont
finalement embarqués on regarde
jusqu'ici tout va bien
si j'en suis arrivé là
c'est que j'avais pas le choix je suis
un peu pour récupérer ta carte
j'ai toujours rêvé de présenter le JT
s
j'ai mis des années pour y arriver
aujourd'hui ma vie allait changer
[Musique]
il fait de la location de voiture il est
dans n'importe quoi il est dans
l'import-export de la location de la
voiture
37 ans je voulais pas te mêler à tout ça
je présente le JT je vais griller en
deux deux faut qu'on bouge cette caisse
si les keufs la trouve ici je suis cuite
on a une tête envers Oumar je vais te
voir m'occuper de ta famille toi
c'est toi qui va payer
quand même
ça veut dire quoi régler ça veut dire
quoi nous-même
génération de femmes ce frère bien sûr
le sens de la famille aussi l'ambition
personnelle votre ambition personnelle à
vous dans dans ce rôle de journaliste
comment vous avez eu cette cette idée
Nawel comment toutes les choses se sont
enclenchées
il y a eu plusieurs événements je dirais
que le premier a été j'accompagnais
Djibril votre compagnon qui joue ce
baron de la drogue ou Marc c'est méchant
mais des beaux méchants
en pleine promo de des Misérables
plusieurs réflexions concernant les
femmes peu présentes dans le film
et c'est vrai que je fais tout de suite
une analyse de la haine jusqu'au
misérable jusqu'à dernièrement
Athéna ou
d'autres films voilà qui traitent de la
banlieue des cités ainsi de suite
bah la femme est peu présente voire pas
du tout représenté et je leur mets voilà
ils ont ouvert des portes ils ont ils
ont ramené un genre et je me suis dit
tiens il faut raconter aussi ces femmes
qui sont présentes courageuses
vaillantes qui sont les lignes de force
de la famille et je commence à écrire et
je me soucie pas du genre en fait au
début
je pars sur une histoire un peu
dramatique et je me dis par la suite on
va on va venir puncher tout ça et arrive
le confinement et moi qui pensais
revenir sur scène rapidement et
en fait la série prend prend le pas sur
tout le reste des projets est-ce que
vous avez
tiré ou vous êtes nourris un petit peu
des éléments de votre famille parce que
vous êtes vous issus d'une famille de
quatre enfants trois sœurs vous êtes
celle du milieu d'ailleurs oui même
ma sœur a été voilée
elle a un enfant invalide mon douceur à
deux ans de fils qu'elle élève seule
je suis la seule qui qui je me suis
mariée tard je suis partie de la maison
je suis assez je suis celle qui
bousculent un petit peu j'ai cette
humour cette humour il est il est
présent chez moi
aussi un mot quand même de Djibril
évidemment votre compagnonga le papa de
votre petite loup
le faire tourner ça c'est une chose le
diriger et puis il y a aussi être maman
jeune maman de cette petite fille
pendant que vous fabriquez la série et
pendant que vous tournez dedans
qu'est-ce qui a été le plus compliqué si
j'ose dire même si évidemment on peut
pas mettre ça sur le même plan mais
qu'est-ce qui a été le plus laborieux
Nawel entre cette séparation avec votre
petite et diriger votre compagnon qui
qui ont imagine à une vraie personnalité
c'est-à-dire les gens le voient comme ça
poser
c'est vrai que c'est c'est quelqu'un qui
qui aime plus observer que parler mais
quand il parle mon dieu ça a été la
personne pour moi la plus difficile à
diriger sur le plateau parce que je suis
sa femme il se permet plein de choses
d'ailleurs il m'appelle sur le plateau
choupinette je dis au moins appelle-moi
madame choupinette
donc oui ça a été ça a été pour moi
mais ça a pas été la chose la plus
compliquée
me séparer de ma fille ça a été la chose
la plus dure je suis retournée au
travail très rapidement
après peut-être un mois même pas trois
semaines
il fallait il fallait y retourner
et
je me suis effondrée je me souviens
après le quatrième jour de mon
accouchement j'étais à l'hôpital et je
disais à dubridge j'ai pas envie en fait
de me séparer de ce bébé que j'ai
tellement attendu
et là c'est un beau bébé qui vit sa vie
en tout cas votre petite loup mais cette
série jusqu'ici tout va bien ce que vous
m'entendez là ouais j'ai juste dès que
je parle de tout ça ça veut enfin
ma fille elle m'a tellement manqué
durant cette période
c'était pas facile non une vraie maman
accomplie elle sera fière de vous quand
elle regardera quand elle sera en âge de
regarder je vous ai dit que j'étais
motivé attention mais je sais que vous
enchaînez là pour que je passe à autre
chose
mais c'est fou il va falloir que que je
me fasse accompagnée par un coach parce
que dès qu'on touche à des points comme
ça c'est c'est que ce soit ma fille mes
parents dès que j'ai aucun contrôle
c'est c'est c'est ça qui plaît qu'on
vous aime parce que vous êtes dans la
vérité mais c'est vrai qu'on me dit
qu'on me définit souvent comme femme
forte mais c'est que je suis hyper
sensible et je sais pas faire semblant
c'est à dire que que j'arrive pas à
maîtriser mes émotions c'est c'est ça ça
me prend comme au Marrakech du rire je
me dis allez je vais y aller je vais me
retenir et quand je prends c'est
UGG de 3000 personnes je m'effondre et
c'est à chaque fois le je n'arrive pas à
contrôler ça et pourtant je me dis c'est
c'est cool ma fille va bien grâce à Dieu
tout se passe bien je me disais qu'une
seule chose sacrifiée
ces moments de vie qu'on ne rattrapera
plus parce que c'est la première année
de ma fille que j'ai loupé c'est le mot
qu'il faut dire voilà j'avais un choix
je me suis dit voilà je je
m'éloigne d'elle pour mieux revenir et
m'installer pour pouvoir mieux profiter
j'ai j'ai toujours cette envie de
d'installer ma famille de prendre soin
de mes parents qui se font de plus en
plus âgés et au final quand je regarde
maintenant le succès de cette série je
me dis je me dis allez c'est pas pour
rien Nawel est-ce que est-ce que vous
voulez bien vous installer maintenant
dans un autre espace pour vivre un autre
moment ensemble ce que vous êtes
d'accord à côté d'Oran la baie vitrée
vous avez un fauteuil gris vous allez
pouvoir vous y installer confortablement
et on va discuter bien sûr à la fois de
la scène
elle est toute Pâques à la fois de la
Seine évidemment des États-Unis enfin
tout ce qui vous constitue bien sûr je
vous en prie installez-vous la
télécommande est à droite
j'appuie au milieu
la première mesdames mesdemoiselles
messieurs elle a un peu le trac elle est
belle elle est sexy elle a un goût de
paradis mesdames messieurs elle
s'appelle nawell Madani
[Musique]
bon moi je m'appelle Nawel comme il vous
l'a dit et je suis Maurice et je viens
d'une famille du Maurice et la plus
grande humoriste de ma famille ça reste
ma mère tous les jours on m'appelle
depuis que je monte sur scène pour me
donner des blagues
pour toi Maman mais arrête avec
tes blagues cochonnes elle me dit si les
Français ils aiment bien ça mais
attention attention dis pas ton père
c'est moi qui te les donne il croit
encore que je suis vierge
ma mère elle me fait des blagues et
dernièrement j'étais un peu stressée
elle m'a emmené au hammam pour me
relaxer vous connaissez hammam là-bas
ils ont pas une masseuse ils ont une
catcheuse salam alikoum pour le massage
oui installe-toi là tu es frotter tout
tu vas voir
mais quoi j'ai pas revu ça
depuis ça a diffusion même je pense non
c'est quoi il y a 12 ans à peu près une
dizaine d'années effectivement c'est là
que le public français comment ça vous
découvrir bien sûr et c'est précisément
papy Alain Degois qui qui vous découvre
qui avait lui découvert Jamel Debbouze
il va neuf et tant d'autres qui qui en
fait d'abord vous rencontre dans un taxi
puis ensuite il vient je crois vous voir
jouer dans le bar c'est moi le chauffeur
c'est moi qui vais chercher
quelqu'un à l'aéroport il monte dans la
voiture on échange
je lui dis que je fais du stand-up que
ça marche hyper bien que je cartonne
jouer dans une salle de 30 personnes
et qu'il faut absolument venir me voir
que c'est au chapeau
donc moi je faisais vraiment je vais
essayer de remplir ma salle c'est le jeu
de chaque humoriste le challenge chaque
humoriste qui débute et il vient me voir
plusieurs jours plus tard et bien me
voir et en sortie de scène il me fait
des retours quand tu joues tu tangues
quand tu balances ta vanne fixe-toi
il me donne vraiment des retours à cette
technique
et il me dit voilà je je vais devenir le
nouveau directeur artistique du Jamel
Comedy Club
j'aimerais que tu viennes faire des
essais
je lui dis mais attends c'est quoi ce
truc de malade quoi et je fais mon
passage et juste derrière il me dit
bienvenue dans la troupe du diamètre
ça faisait que trois mois que je jouais
c'est inouï comme moment évidemment
c'est un moment important pour vous et
en même temps un moment compliqué aussi
enfin en tout cas les mois qui se
poursuivent sont pas nécessairement à
l'image de ce que vous espériez
c'est dur d'être la seule fille de la
troupe je suis la seule fille et je suis
pas au niveau
les mecs qui sont là font les premières
parties de Jamel des Zénith il joue tous
les soirs font tous les clubs de
stand-up ils ont fait déjà de la télé
des chroniques
ils ont une vanne toutes les 15 secondes
moi je débute
et quand on commence bah on a le rire
facile je fais des accents comme vous le
voyez je fais des forcer le trait je
force le trait je suis dans voilà je
j'apprends en fait et mais par contre le
public ne le sait pas
et et eux se demandent mec j'arrive est
vraiment dans dans la troupe je suis
voilà on passe les uns après les autres
et je suis vraiment le creux de la vague
enfin c'est le ventre mou de du
spectacle
et il se demande tiens pourquoi on m'a
sélectionné est-ce que parce que il faut
absolument une femme parce que
parce que vous êtes jolie très très
jolie femme très jolie jeune femme merci
merci
et du coup je me dis qu'est-ce que je
fous là et je commence à jouer entre 7
et 9 fois par soir dans les clubs de
stand-up je me tape
et je vais je vais être au niveau quoi
et je joue tout le temps tout le temps
tout le temps et je me dis on m'a donné
cette place il faut que je la garde
et bien sûr que j'ai eu des des
remarques
hardcore déplacées
ou du public vous voulez bien appuyer
sur le bouton s'il vous plaît
et sans m'en rendre compte tout
naturellement et j'étais tombé amoureuse
de la danse
j'aimais tous chez elle sous attitude
son arrogance son charisme
à nous deux on formait plus qu'un
j'ai passé ma vie à danser
j'attendais le bus en menson
partout j'allais elle me suivait
avec la danse je me sentais féminine
elle me transportait avec la danse je me
voyais toucher les étoiles regarde la
danse ensemble on va toucher les
histoires
avec la danse je me voyais descendre les
vallées de l'hymoud Holly
et là c'est votre spectacle c'est moi la
plus belle
triomphe fait tourner pendant 4 ans un
grand show de 2h30 parce que vous ne
comptez pas vous voulez que votre public
en est pour son argent vous montrez tous
vos talents d'humoriste mais aussi
danseuse parce qu'il faut savoir qu'en
fait la danse c'est votre vocation
initiale exactement c'est vraiment ça et
Michael Jackson je crois gamine qui vous
sauve et qui vous révèle en quelque
sorte à vous
Michael avait
Michael genre c'est mon pote Michael
mimi comme on dit à la maison non mais
Michael
j'avais je me reconnaissais en lui je me
reconnaissais en lui déjà physiquement
le tempo
le néant trompette
vraiment je
me reconnaissais en Michael Jackson et
puis il avait subi le même accident
domestique enfin c'est à dire il a il a
il avait aussi eu une brûlure
3e degré effectivement au niveau du cuir
chevelu et du coup je me dis mais
Michael il a été brûlé
et c'est une star
bah moi peut-être un jour pareil vous
serez quand même chorégraphe pendant un
certain temps vous allez vous former
aussi aux États-Unis je sais que vous
arrivez à Paris vous vous installez vous
avez une vingtaine d'années
c'est tendu cette période là c'est la
galère je dors dans ma voiture je me
lave à la piscine du 19e
et
j'ai acheté des paquets de Kellogg's
avec lesquels je mangeais je peux que ça
me nourrissait le matin midi le soir
avec avec du lait demi-écrémé que je
gardais dans le coffre de ma voiture
c'était période difficile de ma vie des
formatrice qui ont mais tellement on
fait un détour par l'Olympia quand même
quand il y a les lettres rouges avec
votre nom Nawel Madani c'est moi la plus
belle je crois que votre papa assiste
enfin et pour la première fois à un de
vos spectacle ce que vous vous souvenez
bien sûr de ce moment votre émotion la
sienne
bah mon père en fait
il a été
très dur avec moi dans le sens où
il m'a il avait peur pour moi c'est
c'est je suis la petite dernière celle
qui a subi un accident donc ils étaient
en surprotection constante
et moi j'avais soif soif d'exister soif
de trouver ma place je j'étais animé par
quelque chose qui qui dépassait tout le
monde en fait et il y a une rupture
vraiment il m'a dit
tu pars sans mon consentement
et là moi là-bas la baraka des parents
elle est essentielle chez nous il faut
que tu pars avec l'accord des parents
sinon il va t'arriver que des misères et
je veux que mon père soit fier de moi
c'est ça devient un moteur et il devient
ma muse c'est à dire que ma mère celle
qui m'a soutenu depuis le début
je pense même plus à elle c'est pour
vous dire c'est à dire c'est quand même
ingrat c'est celle qui qui croit en moi
qui casse la tirelire qui me donne de
ses économies
qui me dit ah ouais tiens tu as un
problème je suis là moi je crois en toi
c'est même plus ça veut dire c'est
mon film c'est mon père le spectacle
c'est mon père justement ce film et oui
parce que votre défi il a fallu aller
évidemment jusqu'au bout il fallait que
vous racontiez cette histoire il fallait
il fallait que vous alliez au bout de
cette histoire avec lui avec votre papa
regardons si vous voulez bien une image
c'est vous qui appuyez pardon
je peux pas
tu peux pas quoi tu peux pas rentrer en
Belgique après tout ce qui s'est passé
tu parles de quoi
tu dis des choses à faire ici j'ai
rencontré des gens bien les gens bien
en prison encore des gens bien c'est la
meilleure
[Musique]
c'est quoi tu me connais pas
c'est pas qui je suis
plus mentir
qui t'attend on t'a préparé ta chambre
et tes copines qui t'attendent
voilà la suite de l'histoire c'est 2017
c'est tout pour moi votre premier film
en tant que réalisatrice en
collaboration avec Ludovic colgo Justin
c'est toujours dans la série avec moi
absolument et oui c'est l'histoire de
lilas finalement qui parle de vous cette
danseuse n'en déplaise à son père Paris
etc ce que vous nous racontiez
comment il l'a vécu ce film votre papa
mon père est
très pudique
et Tupac allez viens et mon père qui
enfin moi la famille c'est tout quoi
c'est c'est ce qui me permet d'avancer
c'est ce qui tue pas que tu es pas
content
[Musique]
mais non mais ça ressemble à
alors
mon papa je l'ai je l'ai je l'ai appelé
pour savoir si il avait il avait entendu
parler de la série
il m'a dit écoute
tu es en train de faire tu es en train
de faire tu fais bouger des lignes et tu
et là tu provoques le débat
tu provoque le débat
c'est le plus important
retiens le bon
toujours se remettre en question
ton attention était était bonne
moi je suis fière de toi
et je crois que
c'est la première fois qu'il me le dit
comme ça et ça ça vaut tout l'or du
monde
on a envie de vous voir vous mouvoir
vous voulez bien faire quelque part dans
l'appartement
la musique ça compte beaucoup pour vous
évidemment Tupac mais une femme qui
compte beaucoup c'est Beyoncé je crois
que vraiment c'est aussi un marqueur de
votre vie je vais pas vous faire je vais
pas vous faire danser comme Beyoncé bien
qu'on adorerait vous voir danser je peux
vous le dire dans la bibliothèque
regardez juste derrière vous voilà
légèrement à droite un certain nombre de
disques de livres etc qui parle de vous
nous on a fait notre petite sélection à
notre sauce qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
alors ça c'est
toute mon enfance et c'est c'est le film
break Street 84
où je découvre turbo et Auxonne de danse
ça
et c'est là où tout commence pour moi et
avec mon père on écoutait ça dans le
salon
[Musique]
il est trop fort ce morceau intemporel
j'adore ce morceau
pour l'avoir dans la bande-annonce de
mon film
écoute un
brassement
que la musique qui est d'ailleurs très
présente dans ma série
c'est un budget et et
ce morceau avec mon père on
danse le dimanche dans le salon on se il
nous mettait des morceaux que ça soit
Otis Redding mon père adore la musique
vraiment on passait de
du du rythme blues au rail quoi ça
passait de Khaled à
Barry White c'est
c'est vrai qu'on a envie de monter le
son quand on entend ça et danser
j'adore ce morceau
[Musique]
j'adore
ce morceau il est incroyable
[Musique]
ah là là
on a évidemment
une tradition dans l'émission nous aussi
on offre des cadeaux bien sûr vous allez
aperçu peut-être le bouquet de fleurs
qui est dans l'angle du canapé à gauche
ouais avec une petite boîte
et vous pouvez l'ouvrir bien sûr bah
c'est bien normal
[Musique]
alors oui parce que vous êtes quand même
vous êtes une active voire une
hyperactive et maintenant vous allez
vous poser un petit peu avec votre
petite fille et c'est donc une box de
méditation et de sophrologie pour un peu
plus de zéniture pour être comme ça en
coulititude même si j'ose dire j'adore
vous allez voir c'est hyper pousser
attention merci beaucoup est-ce que vous
voulez bien nous laisser une photo de
vous Nawel dans la bibliothèque derrière
vous
juste derrière près du bar voilà vous
allez voir l'appareil photo deuxième
étagère si vous voulez bien appuyer pour
l'allumer d'abord sur la petite pastille
orange
voilà et ensuite prendre la petite
télécommande en main
et là ça fonctionne
parfait merci beaucoup Nawel ça ça reste
avec nous si vous voulez bien le cliché
va sécher et on va le garder voilà merci
merci beaucoup Nawel merci
merci pour l'accueil plein de bonnes
choses avec cette série qui cartonne
déjà sur Netflix et on attend la suite
j'espère hein vous reviendrez bah
n'oubliez pas votre cadeau
et puis et puis le spectacle en Belgique
dans cette salle que vous avez créé le
nouvel acte à Bruxelles bien sûr
exactement on voit des jeunes humoristes
qui font leur premier pas tout comme moi
au Jamel Comedy Club et
un prochain spectacle donc oui je
j'espère vous revoir la prochaine fois
allez merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup pour le cadeau merci pour
votre délicate attention merci à vous
c'était adorable plein de bonnes choses
à vous je vous embrasse moi aussi je
vous embrasse merci encore pour le
cadeau
j'en peux plus de moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]